you know I came to this video playing
haga from Spain let's see I usually
plane what black the guy was always
playing 1b3 wears a bit strange I mean
v3 is not a bad move but really every
game okay so we have a Rubenstein French
I cannot really claim any pic knowledge
in check just develop yeah at least I
cannot I don't need to worry about any
bad pieces what I cannot take on the f6
and on h7 rue creators of really relaxed
shines check check okay so let's see him
I hope I'm really winning now I'm not
just drawing be a bit disappointing if
it was just it would just be it wrong I
think it is 97 or not or is there was
something better even
yeah okay this is a good I'm threatening
Knight f6 and I was threatening the
Queen and if he takes rook takes that's
the bishop on b7 hanging at the bishop
on f6 hanging and i hope you cannot
defend all of that maybe you can ship c6
okay rook rook d6 on its there been
another good news somewhere that I'm not
seeing okay I should probably play at
some point this isn't too clear good
look at two points against two bishops
why did I go to d3 and rook h3 mate ah
come on I could have just played group d
three I put it on the only square where
doesn't have allowed to play rook t3 now
I sometimes I'm just a complete idiot
rook t3 m3 just resigns after that move
and deservedly I mean what the heck okay
yeah it's still good for height but
rocky III a tree hmm it's just over
well okay if it moves the bishop on f6
now anywhere anyway anywhere anywhere
mother's just Queen g6 i'm picking up
fz6 bishop this is six bishop however is
pinned down young it's probably take
here twice or look you one how do
actually actually win now and probably
need another piece in that tech and
fortunately does not look on one I could
have played look III h3a come on why did
not play rookie three again I could one
I could win okay I Bishop d7 maybe ok
this guy he already must think I'm brain
dead or something ok I can at least I
see this means now takes Queen takes win
the rook Wow
yeah this is really lucky that I'm still
winning after missing all those moves
yeah sometimes do you have a physician
that is that is so good that it it
actually can can take some some some
inferior moves and still still winning
yes probably letting the clock run down
being a bit frustrated that I two times
after my miss Ruby 383 black resigned
well no move but it should've just
completely blind here yeah roped III
enter and it's over to stern just like
that I can't play this move though yeah
okay it's plus 5 and the computer gives
plus 5 and this should still keep an
edge but oops too much yeah this
actually ok and now we had this also
rupee eight but this is quite quite good
enough yeah I was I was very very
surprised that he played group t8 so
quickly because this is a very typical
idea of the sacrifice and okay they're
very standard therefore you cannot
within this kind of situation you rarely
can move the look on a paid so I was a
bit shocked that he played this
instantly no no way kay-kay to defend
him 97's flat flat out winning yeah
route III of course okay i hope you
enjoyed it anyway thanks for watching